there's a parent from what was on the
blackboard when I walked in that a
midterm exam has been given in some
course and so I want to announce the
midterm exam for this course which does
it take home and I'm going to read the
question so that those people who are
not enrolled and never want to take an
exam again will know what they are
missing one question it says in the
preface to a book containing essays
exploring ways in which singular
hypothetical events such as battles lost
rather than one successful rather than
unsuccessful assassinations etc might
have derailed the course of Western
history three distinguished historians
conclude that prior to about ad 1500 it
is easy to throttle the baby in its
cradle there seem to be innumerable
possibilities for redirecting history so
that the West never Rises
beyond the state it becomes
progressively more difficult to find
single junctures at which it is
plausible to suppose that but for this
events would have led the world down a
markedly different path after 1800 is
virtually impossible to a halt or
reverse the rise of the West although
one can easily envisage it being either
more benign or more malign alright
that's the quote making use of material
and the earth and as people's Robert
marks origins in the modern world and
the lectures in the current in this
course write an essay discussing the
notion of inevitability with respect to
the seemingly dominant role of Europe in
world history between 1500 and 1900
questions you might address include but
are not limited to the relative
importance of political as opposed to
economic history the significance of
quantitative measures of change such as
population size production of particular
goods etc the role of ideology and our
religion and our philosophy global
differences in scientific outlook
technology and access to resources human
factors such as social organization
class education and rural as opposed to
urban life military affairs and chance
yeah okay
I showed this to a learning colleague in
the department he read through and he
said wow what an opportunity for
and I was quite proud I thought
well you know you can ask students to do
various things in a course one thing you
asked for them is to acquire a command
of some of some content so that you can
ask them a question you know what
happened this time or who was so-and-so
and they'll be able to answer the
question and be able to applaud them and
say oh you are a very wise student
because you have learned this content
another way of looking at a course is to
say that it is trying to encourage
people to to think of things and that is
what this course is about basically this
is this is a show-off course in public
thinking on my part and I want to give
you a chance to do your own thinking
although not in quite so public forum
nevertheless that being said utter beer
utter will not be encouraged in
other words you know simply to riff on
the word inevitability it's like what is
inevitable what what is not inevitable
being is being everything surely is
inevitable it could not have been
otherwise because it is wait what this
is not what I'm looking for here
I'm looking for here for some some
specific arguments with respect to
specifics of his and teaching assistants
who will grade the exams in the
undergraduate sections are probably not
nearly as tolerant of idle vapor rings
as I might be so so when you I'll post
this this question I'll send it in to
everyone in an email so you get it
probably this later this evening or
tomorrow and you will have until a
November 10th to to compose your reply
the recommended length is 2,000 words
okay now well so much for the midterm in
the summer of 1960 and starting here
with ancient history I came home from
college to discover to my horror that my
mother had arranged for me to have a job
for the summer I was then and I've
always been really indisposed toward
work Theresa I'm a professor and I
discovered that I was going to have to
work for the county surveyor in
Winnebago County and northern Illinois
and he was in the process of having
drawn a set of maps under his
supervision and the maps would show all
the property in the county and somebody
had to look at the tax records which
consisted of who was paying tax on a
property and compared the tax records
with the with the deeds to see who
actually owned the property make sure
that the property described in the tax
records correspond to to the description
of the property as owned and that might
not seem terribly demanding but the fact
of the matter is the event that I spent
an entire summer and Lea in a vault
in the County Recorder's office pulling
down metal bound volumes with copies of
deeds and looking through them and
checking the data against other things
and of course I blew off my job most of
the day I still got more done than
anyone else had who had been hired to do
the job because they were bluing that
blowing off the whole day and I looked
at a lot of Deeds look the history of
the county I was living in the history
of the city I was living in and it was
really quite fascinating could I'd look
at the original Platts and how Lots were
laid out and how the streets were laid
out I run across things like here's a
person who owns a piece of property
that's three inches wide and you know a
400 feet long and it's in the middle of
a current you know public street and
trying to find how in the world of that
I'd ever come about but one of the
things the most interested me worthy
deeds from the late 40s in particular
maybe into the early 50s I think late
40s only that were had restrictive
covenants they were deeds that said that
the person buying this property agrees
in the purchase of the property never to
transfer this property by sale to any
one of the of the Negro Jewish Italian
Greek or polish races there may have
been more races in land but I remember
those five in particular and ultimately
the Supreme Court struck down
restrictive covenants and they
disappeared from the deeds this is a
well-known episode in American history
and it became you know the striking down
history of restrictive covenants was
later very important in the say in the
civil rights movement and the
integration of of neighborhoods but what
struck me was that
everyone knows that Jews and blacks were
discriminated against in housing but
they don't know that Italians and Greeks
and poles were of course one might
simply say non Protestants but but it
was interesting that all of them are
called races and the naming of races or
the naming of people whom you are
engaged in some sort of exercise of
dominance over these after all a
restrictive covenant is an exercise of
dominance you are you are saying that
people like me the conveyor of the
property are the only people to live
this property we will not allow
Outsiders in and this naming of of
others is a very important aspect of
colonial history it's a broader
philosophical matter in other words say
when you get into the arcane debates
over animal rights one of the things
that you will often run into is verse
chapter 2 verse 20 of the of the book of
Genesis where Adam names the animals and
that is meant to show that humans have
conferred by God dominance over the
animals and that therefore the slaughter
and eating of animals is ordained by God
because he has put the animals all the
animals the sea the air land under the
under the
phenomenal literally the nominal control
of Adam and you get the same thing
presented slightly differently in the
Quran where God presents to Adam the
names of the animals although he doesn't
have the naming and pray precisely the
same way and the whole question of of
what naming means philosophically after
all naming the animals this wasn't
naming you know okay
you are Duke and you're Rex and you're
Fido and this is not naming individual
animals those naming species of animals
and that's that's assumed because only
humans have individual names and this
construction of things other people have
categorical names just as you know you
prohibit the Greeks from living in a
neighborhood but you don't specifically
prohibit a series of Greek surnames my
old college classmate Saul Kripke has
made a major philosophical school out of
asking what is the name and how our
names but the names mean and I've never
understood anything he is written but
he's very famous supposedly one of the
most important philosophers the last 200
years but the fact of the matter is that
I became quite absorbed and have been
for years in the issue of naming and
I've done this several times in this
class talked about research I've done on
the nature of naming and the things that
could be read into naming when it comes
to the chapter that we have for this
week which is Africa India and British
the British colonial empire one of the
things that is very important is the
question of identifying the people over
whom colonial domination is is exercised
this is not something that is particular
to the British nor is it something that
was particularly European colonialism
this is something that has been going on
for hundreds if not thousands of years
in which assigning names categories of
people carries with it a implication of
of domination particularly when the
names are selected by the name ER or
where you have a a wide variety of
possible names and the name arisen plea
selecting a subset of those names to say
these are the significant names for
example one of the most important
intellectual figures in my area of study
islamic history is even called une
you'll be called 'when was a a someone
of andalusia m-- of tunisian of
background and experience with his
cultural background primarily an islamic
spain he lived at the end of the 14th
century his book is the introduction to
history actually the introduction to his
book is well let's say even khaldoun as
the most is the the one Arab name that
generally intellectuals have heard of
after Mohammed and the most important
Arab before Edward side you know there
is no one in between who who is an Arab
who commands that kind of attention and
I got to talk about Edward so you'd
later in this lecture so I'm linking
them here so been called Owen has a
theory of history that I will not go
into I've talked about it in another
lecture but he also
the the big book that he has is on the
history of the Berbers
I'll have the Arabs and the Berbers the
Berbers being the native population of
North Africa and he is an Arab key tabla
live at her feet a tree a lot Arab well
Berber the a book about the Arabs and
the Berbers the Berbers in his
presentation are all descended from
Goliath who it's rather surprising we
all thought he was dead that turns out
that his family went off to North Africa
in this story and became the progenitors
of the native population in North Africa
so you have a an origin story of who the
Berbers were and and then you you you
divide them into tribes and you name the
tribes now prior to the era prior to ban
Khaldoun really are prior to let's say
the earliest Arab sources dealing with
North Africa which go back to the nine
hundreds there isn't any word Berber
there there are people in North Africa
and in Latin and Greek they had names as
peoples those in Algeria were called new
midians those in Morocco or called
borotyn ian's those in North West Libya
are called trepal Italians or North East
Libya where the see Rene Atkins southern
Libya where the the garamantes and there
are a lot of names and we think of them
as sometimes tribal name something like
that but the word Berber doesn't occur
remarkably astute Algerian historian who
teaches at University of Southern
California rm0 Iggy maintains that image
Alduin invented the Berbers and that he
invented the Berbers in exactly the same
way that according to Edward Sayid
Europeans invented the invented the
Orientals invented the Orient that it
was an exercise of of establishing a
type of dominance that that basically
the the invention that the creation of a
of a word that would encompass all the
native North Africans correspondent to
the idea that those people coming from
Spain or from Syria they were Arabs and
they weren't going to mix the Arabs up
and the Berbers the Berbers had their
history the Arabs had their history I
this may seem self-evident except that
by the time he was writing a very large
proportion of people he's calling
Burberry's spoke Arabic rather than
Berber or in addition to Berber in other
words the distinction between Arab and
Berber was not the clear-cut one that's
implied by this by this invented
genealogy we usually think that the word
Berber relates to barbarian and that it
comes from a Greek background that
barbarians or people whose speech was
characterized by being bar bar bar bar
bar so they were the bar bar or the
people who said bar bar and the
repetition of the syllables is important
because the characteristic of animal
sounds in most languages is repetition
so you say you know moo moo or baba or
something like that
arf-arf and you know these people who
were not greeks were people when bar bar
because they were basically animals so
by this construction of it
Berber should have been a pre-existing
word used by Greeks and Romans for the
North Africans because they certainly
were not speaking in their homes the
Greek and Latin languages they were
going bar bar bar bar whatever leave but
barbarians ooh but the fact of matter is
that there's no Greek or Latin text that
actually uses the word
so it's an invented word probably it
seems that the earlier use of the word
is associated mostly with a seaport in
Sudan still known as Barbara that seems
to be the only use of the word prior to
been called in or even called UN's a
sort of a codification of things there
it is used by some earlier Arab sources
and they do not use the tribal names of
the roman period in other words the
romans have a list of tribes and none of
those tribes show up in the arabic
sources so it it's a puzzling sort of
thing but what really gr uses that Arabs
from Spain as the Christians are
reconquering Spain they came to North
Africa as a more sophisticated more
cultured elite than their own minds more
literate dominant elite and they needed
a way of representing the indigenous
population because in that
representation they would be the
superior the superior group now
interestingly this was picked up by the
French after 1840 when they conquered
Algeria and they started to make a
though they said well we must
distinguished distinguish between Arabs
and Berbers but for the French unlike
for imita called une the Berbers were
superior to the Arabs
because French scholars who were
specialist and native population or
North Africa in the early 19th century
and even more you went further in the
19th century believes that before Islam
the native population of North Africa
was Christian and that they were
basically still kind of latent ly
Christian and by being if they ever had
been many of them were questioned
there's no question about that but the
idea that having been Christian in your
family what twelve hundred years earlier
meant that you were more susceptible to
becoming civilized in the 19th century
in the French fashion that seems like a
bit of a stretch particularly when it's
relies on evidence such as the design of
camel saddles so you have a particularly
berber camel saddle and and the front of
it is like that it's like they're some
like handlebars but because oh it's a
cross you know they still have the cross
they still worship the cross they're
still latent ly Christians and so the
Arabs come to be represented as as
Muslims that is to say as barbarians for
the French and the Berbers as a sort of
a primitive but potentially a kradic and
Christian population that the French
could feel better about so that when the
French were thinking in the 1850s or so
about creating using the wonderful
American example creating Arab
reservations where they would herd the
Arabs onto the most desolate land the
way we in this country herded Native
Americans on the most desolate lands
they never did create Arab reservations
but they certainly thought about it they
thought that was a cool idea then the
French could occupy the you know the
better
and that the Arabs had been occupied but
not really benefitting and the way the
French could but the Berbers were not to
be included the burger burgers were to
be sort of singled out for a special
favor the result is that today politics
in Algeria is very strongly inflected
along lines of Arab versus Berber so
that you had one colonialism that goes
back to the 14th century that is saying
Berbers and Arabs are different you have
a second colonialism that goes to the
19th century that says Berbers and Arabs
are different even though the vector of
difference is reversed goes from Arab
superiority to Berber superiority and in
both cases it's a it appears to be a an
intellectual creation of the dominating
group and and yet it takes on a reality
so you can see why this would apply to
India in the 19th century ok maybe you
can't because it's a very obscure
connection perhaps but it relates in the
in British India to the question of
caste and the question of whether what
happened in India was the same thing
that happened with the French and before
them with the Andalusian Arabs in
Algeria that is to say labels that that
existed or at least to a substantial
degree came to be selected as
significant names and then you had a
reification of division signified by
names that that was quite different from
the pre-existing division
the population
the the notion that caste is a you know
not a creation of the British but rather
that it is something that receives its
peculiar significance during the period
of British occupation in India has been
brought out most most explicitly by the
vice-president for academic affairs and
Dean of the Faculty of Columbia
University Nicholas Dirk's in a book
called casts of mine and in that book
Dirk's argues that when the English came
to India in the 18th century became
dominant in one area after another as
agents of the East India Company that
they really weren't very they didn't
talk about caste in particular they
looked at a finer grain sort of thing
like who is who is ruling here who's in
the army who is what's this village like
what is the production like here you go
back to the 18th century descriptions of
India and religious difference doesn't
appear to be the most significant way of
describing the population but by the
second half of the 1800s you have
encyclopedic collections to identify a
name every caste and this gets refined
into the first census of British India
in 1872 and the census proceeds to
identify people by caste for the next
60 or 70 years cast was a not an
invention nobody denies that you had
certain religious groups that could be
identified by their occupation or by
endogamy but they weren't necessarily or
indeed they weren't in all likelihood
the the strongest divisions of the
society in every area but once you had
decided that all Indians belong to a
caste except those who are outcasts who
are who are defined as in a lower order
or who are Muslims who are not
supposedly a part of the caste system
then you had a means not only of
dividing and classifying the population
but also a means of arguing that this
population can't really by itself
constitute a modern society because
caste created this way as with the
Berbers whomever called une traced back
to Goliath caste is seen as primordial
it's part of the first order of humanity
that's what primordial means so it
becomes something that can be studied
the primary source that people would go
to for the start of this is in the Rig
Veda in book 10 of the Rig Veda him
number 92 him known as the purusha sukta
and it's about
being named Perugia actually it should
be it's just an ass with the dot under
it so that the Sanskrit among you do not
get offended about it's pronounced Peru
sir a thousand heads hath Purusha a
thousand eyes a thousand feet on every
side pervading earth he fills a space
ten fingers wide
this Purusha is all that yet hath been
and all that is to be the lord of
immortality
when the gods prepared the sacrifice
with Purusha as their offering its oil
with spring the holy gift was autumn the
summer was the wood they bombed as
victim on the grass Purusha born in
earliest time with him the deities and
all son who's a nurse she sacrificed so
we have yours the idea that you have a
primordial being Purusha and that being
is sacrificed on an altar or at an altar
by the gods themselves okay from that
general sacrifice the dripping fat was
gathered up he formed the creatures of
the air and animals both wild and tame
from it were horses born from it all
cattle with two rows of teeth from it
were generated kind from it the goats
and sheep were born when they divided
Purusha how many portions did they make
what do they call his mouth his arms but
though they call his thighs and feet the
Brahman I would say the priest was his
mouth of both his arms were the rajanya
made these are the Warriors the Shah
trios his thighs became the vices his
fit from his feet the Shudra was
produced these are the four orders of
society the parent structure from which
the castes are thought to derive each
one is made from a different part of
Purusha these four orders are called
varnas word that means color
the moon was gendered from his mind and
from his eye the Sun had birth Indra and
ugh me from his mouth or born those are
two gods well and vie you from his
breath why use the god of the wind forth
from his navel came midair the sky was
fashioned from his head earth from his
feet and from his car the regions thus
they formed the worlds so Purusha is the
source of creation this is the great
creation myth of the of the Vedic
tradition it is obviously has some
parallel with the Adam myth that is say
the animals are not here named by
Purusha but rather they're actually part
of Purusha but more important from an
from the point of view of people trying
to think structurally about India we
would now call it structurally but you
know think generally would probably be a
better term from the 19th century more
important was the idea that the groups
of people were defined by being made for
up from parts of Purusha then within
each Varna you had you had caps
the word jati is the closest we have in
English to the word cast in this smaller
sense although often when you read
descriptions of cast they will lump the
varnas and the jaw tease together the
word cast itself was a Portuguese term I
mentioned it in talking about the new
world how mixed-race people in the new
world form different casts by this
construction of things there's a
primordial division of the Indian
population into groups that are defined
by occupation are defined by costume are
defined by marriage practices and
normally and dogyum II and they're
defined by taboo relationships having to
do with who is permitted to eat with
whom who is permitted to touch somebody
who is permitted to to prepare food and
these castes are seen as the primordial
structure of India and taken together
they constitute Hinduism yeah all right
when you go into say earlier pre British
tanks say lb Rudy's book on India of
famous Muslim scholar the barniz may be
described but the the idea that every
Indian belongs to a specific an alter a
novel unalterable group isn't there and
in fact you have many more divisions
that that we might describe as divisions
of tribe or divisions of status or power
or something like that it's not just a
conjurer ease of try of caste that make
up India so you might say well the
people who who described the caste
system were obviously people who were
consumed with thoughts of a religious
textual a real of textually conveyed
religious differences differences that
were recognized by Indian scholars and
were picked up and made a cornerstone of
British a British control of the
population by intellectuals
administrators working for the British
administration in India in that sense
people have argued that caste was
invented by the British this doesn't
mean that there were not divisions that
come to be labeled in this rather rigid
structure as being cast differences nor
does it mean that all those labels were
truly as they later come to be described
but you can say that if you felt this
line of argument that the British
invented caste and that they invented
caste in order to to to dominate the
native population of India they
dominated them politically economically
militarily but now they're dominating
them in a sense culturally by saying
that their organization of society has
been unchanging for 2,000 years
and therefore the modernization of the
society depends upon getting rid or
overcoming or going beyond the divisions
of caste because the Indians really
can't do that by themselves because they
are locked into this this primordial
system of divisions now this kind of
thinking in which you you say that the
colonial power invents or selectively
deploys names of things names for groups
of people for the purpose of dominating
them or ascribes intrinsic status to
certain groups for example groups
considered like warlike tribes or
peoples and others consider not warlike
this sort of thing is part and parcel of
what we now think of as post-colonial
thinking and to say those people who
come from or are deeply involved
intellectually with societies that were
under colonial rule throughout the 19th
century in particular are
very much interested in reassessing what
that colonialism actually did and that
reassessment is is very important when I
came to Colombia the person into whose
office I moved was a very distinguished
Christian Arab economic historian named
Charles II sali very highly respected
everyone always liked Charles a very
witty man but when he taught economic
history he was interested in in drawing
up a balance sheet
you know Cloney ilysm good or bad you
know let's measure the number of miles
of railroad or increase in productivity
or investment on the part of the
colonial power in ways that did not
necessarily repay the colonial power and
he would generally come to the
conclusion that you know on balance
colonialism was probably okay and maybe
even pretty good that these countries
whether they were in the Middle East
which was his most most of his concern
he wrote about Turkey and the Arab world
and Iran or whether it was farther
afield in India people of history of
mind were saying that the way you should
appraise the colonial era is sort of
objectively in terms of the the outcome
was it beneficial was it not beneficial
and he would say as an economist that
you know unbalanced it was pretty
beneficial okay what the the alternative
you really looked at the question well
beneficial for whom and who is being
left out of that of that of that party
of that the people who enjoy some sort
of benefit in India this
inquiry which began in India more than
any other place took the form of a
school of thought known as the subaltern
school the subaltern theorists took
their term subaltern from the writings
of an italian marxist named Antonio
Gramsci gram she was a influential very
influential Marxist historian who some
of his most important works were the
things he wrote when he was imprisoned
and fascist Italy wrote the 1920s early
1930s his
he and a number of other Marxist writers
of that time were strongly interested in
the fact that there had not been a
communist revolution in Germany or other
developed countries you know the fine
there was a communist revolution in
Russia but why Russia was a primitive
country by comparison with Germany or
France or Italy and these stresses of
bourgeois society should have been more
evident in these other countries and yet
no revolution so they got involved and
particularly members of this group
worked in in Frankfurt and Germany
they're often called the front four at
school and gram she is derivative from
the Frankfurt School in the Miss respect
they had the idea that the way bourgeois
society works is not simply through
owning the means of production and
grinding the faces of the poor in
factory labor causing the poor to to
rebel but rather they exercise a kind of
intellectual hegemony and hegemony is
the key word for gram Chi
the exercise of hegemony that comes from
their ownership of or dominance of the
the intellectual discourse of the
society they're the ones who write the
books they're the ones who who produce
the popular culture
they're the ones who who sort of assess
what what is a value or not a value in a
society and through this domination
through this intellectual hegemony or
cultural hegemony would be more broad
they lure the oppressed population into
concurring with the oppressors you know
people lose sight of their objective
interest and say you know it'd really be
better if millionaires got a big tax
break because even though I'm unemployed
you know one day I might be a
millionaire right that's part of the
mbuna and that through this through
adroit compromises made with labor
unions in which they're given a sort of
half a loaf and through their assignment
of the scale of values they delude the
oppressed population into seeing things
in their fashion all right there's a
tremendous amount of literature on this
that goes down to all sorts of things
like you know pop music as the opiate of
the masses and things like that but when
it comes to to the colonial arena which
Graham she did not write about and in
general if it's it's stone
it was it was an area that the Marxist
were were not terribly well equipped to
deal with theoretically but in the
colonial area the idea arose that the
the domination that grant she identified
as cultural hegemony in the European
context was being carried out by people
who who come to be labeled as
Orientalists and here we get to Edwards
side in 1978 Edward Sayid who taught
English here at Columbia wrote a book
called Orientalism very much derivative
in its notion of hegemony from from the
work of Graham Chi and from the work of
the French thinker Foucault who has
whose notion of hegemony was focused on
the way in which the Enlightenment has
deceived us all into thinking that the
value of the Enlightenment are actually
good and actually they suck
so what's he was looking at were
theorists who said that the writers the
thinkers the people who produce the
books are not simply isolated and an
ivory tower but rather they are the
instruments of a very powerful mechanism
that is designed to create systems of
domination systems of domination in
Europe would include the you know the
persistence of of bourgeois capitalism
or the
persistence of enlightenment based
pseudo scientific rationality that
defines things like sexual orientation
or okay you flunk your midterm Howard if
she didn't turn off your machine so this
domination you know take certain forms
in Europe and what Sayid did it was
really quite a a brilliant move was to
say that this notion of hegemony is
carried out in the colonial arena
specifically the part of the Cloney
arena he knew something about namely the
Middle East or the Arab world is carried
out through the through the works of
scholars who write interpretive studies
that are designed to show that the
people living under the colonial
domination of say the French and the
British in the Middle East are in fact
living in a unchanging primordial system
that is incapable of modernizing or
changing in a progressive fashion in the
same way that caste
in India gets portrayed as this sort of
primordial template that prevents the
Indians from changing in a positive in a
positive direction therefore making it
necessary for the colonial overlords to
be the agents of lifting up the local
peoples lifting them out of there out of
their primordial swamp and leading them
into a better day so in other words the
thinkers who wrote about these areas in
in Syed's construction of things
were collaborators in the domination of
of the Orient the word he chose to use
orientalists Orientalism was a
pre-existing word it had been used
throughout the 19th century it had been
embodied in a number of organizations
such as the american oriental society
the notion of being an Orientalist was
up until saeed
looked upon as a as a worthy calling
there were if you looked into the
antecedents of Orientalism and you
looked at how did they study these areas
that were colonial areas and you asked
did they study them with imperialism in
mind was that was that their goal in a
few cases it can be argued that well yes
they were working for the Dutch or the
French or the English Imperial
authorities but in most cases they were
just professors or in Syed's rather
expansive initiative orientalism they
were tourists people who went to Egypt
or Tunisia to paint pictures or write
travel logs or write novels and that
full of their writing all of their
portrayals the photographs they took the
paintings that they came home with
contributed to the construction of an
image of the Orient as being backward
weak slothful of the one-hand overly
puritanical but on the other hand overly
obsessed with sexuality and so forth and
so on and also they dressed funny so
scientists had a in the people he talked
about the scholars and the tourists
it was rather different from the people
whom Nick Dirk's talks about who are
taught who are dealing of caste in India
they're very explicitly the scholars who
are involved our scholars who are
contributing to the administration of
British India they are working for the
British if they are compiling census
records based on caste or they're
writing a dictionary of an encyclopaedia
of caste something like that they are
part of the of the administration the
subaltern school that looked upon this
kind of concern with caste and with
fixed categories names that were
assigned by the British administrators
and tried to speak on behalf of the of
the people who were being ignored in the
historical records and there's some
brilliant small-scale studies by
subaltern historians to show how simply
the way of British administration straw
diet or describe a an incident in some
area would be distorted by my little
about the categories that that he had to
to deploy and that if you found other
sources you would find that it was it
was different from that in other words
say something that I mentioned before
the the perusal of the police
interrogations and the eight trigrams
rebellion in Qing China at the same time
and how a rebellion that might have been
simply were trade as an assassination
attempt against the Emperor
once you actually got the raw police
material turns into a very very
different type of extremely wide-ranging
popular the Senate based upon Buddhist
messianism the subalterns are trying to
find is it kitten can we find instances
where we can hear the actual voices of
the people as opposed to reading the
British accounts a filtered through the
pre-existing British conceptions of what
is important and what is unimportant but
when it came to Sayid working on the
Middle East the fact that matter is that
most the Middle East was not occupied by
the French of the British until after
World War one Egypt's occupied in 1880
and he doesn't make much of much of
sanction between North Africa which was
occupied from 1840 and on and Algeria
and the Middle East which remains
farther afield from this what what he
does in creating the notion of of an
intellectual establishment that that
achieves on behalf of a dominant
imperialist power a type of cultural
hegemony what he does is create the
general category within which the
subaltern school finds a place the
subaltern historians were all Indians
virtually and they wrote only about
India and the whole term of the term
subaltern did not spread you did not
have sub altering studies dealing with
Oh South Africa or Senegal or something
like that but Orientalism by saying that
the intellectual construction of
hegemony is not something specific to
British records in a particular colony
but is part of a general phenomenon
which comes to be called Orientalism and
Syed's label it becomes a general cat
Gouri bike which you can then say that
the entire European colonial enterprise
not simply in India and not simply in in
the Middle East but the entire British
of the entire European colonial
enterprise British French Italian what
have you is structured by intellectual
intellectual models created by people
whom we whom we are pleased to identify
as scholars but who are in a broader
sense agents of of cultural domination
in the same way for example that a a
scholar or a someone in Europe who was
suggesting some way in which a labor
union might be accommodated within a a
capitalist structure in a way that would
satisfy the demands of labor unions in
part might be seen as a as an agent of
this sort of hegemonic activity cultural
hegemony then there is a question of
could these people painters writers
novelists tourists scholars could they
be agents of imperialism without knowing
it those become a very important issue
today in its more raw formulation it is
argued that if you are if you grow up in
a in an imperialist environment as part
of the dominant population in that
environment
then whatever you do with respect to
people who are dominated in the colonial
arena or even closer to home whatever
you do is is unconsciously structured by
the patterns of a privilege and you know
dismissal that you grew up with at this
point we edge rather close to the idea
that the only people who can write about
a subject are people who are who are
native to the population about which the
writing is being done because if they
are people who come from a euro-american
background particularly of older white
male description of which I'm one then
they are agents of imperialism whether
they want to or not because they grew up
in a society of of domination and
therefore their their intellectual
output is going to be constrained within
this unconsciously absorbed model of
privilege and and and domination this
has been very very troubling in certain
areas of academia particularly say in
the field of anthropology anthropology
was pretty much defined by the idea that
you know someone from well somewhere in
Europe or America would go off to a
foreign place and through participant
observation
and be able to describe to write an
ethnography to write a description of
what that what those people were like
how they behaved what was important
about them this the Orientalists frame
of mind begins to suggest that the very
notion that one of these outsiders would
go someplace and be able actually to to
perceive what what was in the nature of
the of the people whom they were
visiting that that was an illusion and
that in fact it was a contributed to to
domination so some of the most prominent
anthropologists come to be thought of by
a later generation as agents of colonial
oppression
you know evans-pritchard for example who
emphasized a kinship structure and as
applied to certain parts of the arab
world
it began to be questioned began to be
asked you know can you you know can a
non member of a group ever describe a
group without that hint of that he or
she does not belong to without being
controlled by this cultural background
are we go that there was a point in
Columbia's checkered history of
anthropology when I chaired the
anthropology department because it was
felt that the anthropology department
was populated by people who were so
immature that they could not be trusted
to run their own affairs and so it was
put in receivership and I was put in as
chairman and I put a big portrait of
home a knee over my desk and said he's
going to run it does her a dictatorship
and I cancelled all
faculty meetings I said if a faculty
can't get along I hope we just won't
have any faculty meetings will they have
a meeting when there's something I we
need to have a vote on and I will summon
the faculty to vote in favor of my
proposal but otherwise we'd have no
faculty we're pretty well they didn't
get along with one another and not
seeing one another helped and then they
could blame all the all the failures on
me but one thing I discovered for a
professor came up for tenure at that
time was that this is a professor who
who wrote about America and she was an
American she wrote a book about downward
mobility in America and one of the
people who wrote on her who wrote you
about her tenure situation said this
person can't be an anthropologist
because anthropology is defined as
writing about other people you can't be
an American and do anthropology writing
about Americans and so then we had a big
quarrel over that she did get tenure she
went to another university became
whatever a distinguished career but but
at that point we were getting that
division between a an old school of
anthropology that said that difference
between the observer and the other the
observed is a crucial thing to a new
phase that said all those old
anthropologists distorted everything
because they didn't really understand
because they couldn't understand they
were part of the structure of domination
they were not not able to to to see
things the way they would be seen from
the inside uh anthropology changed a lot
of this new thinking came into
comparative literature came into history
political science I won't that's so much
political science they're still kind of
Neanderthal but
but but this was a real turning point it
it would not have occurred if Edward
saves work had not coincided with
thinking that was going on elsewhere
particularly among these historians in
India who were giving fine-grained
studies of the distortions that colonial
thinking and colonial administration
produced in the region record as opposed
to Sayid who is primarily interested in
what Europeans had to say about areas
were in fact fine-grained studies of
colonial domination were we're not
exactly non-existent but they certainly
were no nowhere near as important as as
they came to be in as they were in India
those that did exist were primarily from
Egypt and Algeria but he concentrates
more on Egypt than on Algeria so what we
had was a a big change in how one thinks
in the academic world about non
euro-american parts of the world or more
broadly about people who are not part of
the the white dominant population groups
in Europe in America
this gets associated with
multiculturalism and atomistic and a
domestic arena but these things are all
rather interrelated
is so much of what has happened in the
80s and 90s and since in terms of
studying these these non euro American
populations in other parts of the world
so much of it has been devoted to going
back and reconsidering and disproving or
undermining or disowning the scholarship
of the last 200 years that one of the
one of the unforeseen consequences of
this concern for Orientalism and it in
the very broadest sense of the word is a
lessening of actual that's called
empirical scholarship actual
accumulation of new information on some
subject or other because if you're if
you're simply reading archives or
reading pre-modern texts or something
like that
and producing some kind of study there's
always a question of are you
unconsciously being an agent of of
American you know neo imperialism
I could go into detail about how this
has affected Colombia particularly the
removal of three regional Institute's
after 50 years of existence from the
school of international public affairs
because of faculty who do not believe
that the study of international affairs
should include the study of non-western
parts of the world because if Colombia
studies non-western parts of the world
we will be party consciously or
unconsciously to American imperialism in
those areas I happen to strongly
disagree with that that construction of
things but it is gospel truth in the
eyes of many of my colleagues on the
other hand I'm a very old person and I
recognize that things change with
changing generation I'll be 71 next
Sunday and perhaps a more aware of the
divergence between my generation and
colleagues who are 10 to 20 years
younger than I was even last week but
but when it comes to to a chapter like
this this chapter is is it's a good
chapter it tells you a lot of
interesting things oh there are no big
errors in it on the other hand it's very
old-fashioned it does not it sees it
almost in the way that that economic
historian sought of know what was good
what was bad who was oppressed who who
benefited it's the story that we have
inherited from the last generation or
two of people writing about how Europe
encountered the rest of the world in the
era of imperialism but what I've been
reason I decide to focus on this today
is because just to make you aware that
in another 20 years
this kind of chapter will be very
different I would say as the current
intellectual trends deriving from the
subaltern school and from the broad
impact of the notion of Orientalism as
this percolates down from the from the
professorial into the level of textbooks
we're going to see a very different
portrayal of how how and why the British
Empire existed it's very hard to imagine
exactly what it will be like but it will
be I think dramatically different I say
it's very difficult to think how will be
like because this is twenty five after
five and I don't have to think about
what will be like until Thursday but
given two days who knows what will
happen